[موسيقى]
يقول الثنائي موراتا أن unagi كان جزءًا من
حياته طالما أنه يتذكر
أنه بدأ في أكل ثعبان الماء العذب عندما كان
طفلاً صغيرًا ، فأنت أحب
الصلصة حقًا عندما كنا نذهب لتناول السوشي ، لقد
طلبت دائمًا ثعبان البحر في اليابان
unagi  هو طعام صيفي شهير غالبًا ما
يقدم شرائحه المشوية على الأرز
ولكن موراتا يفعل الأشياء بطريقته الخاصة
[موسيقى
] يصنع أطباق صغيرة من
أجزاء مختلفة من ثعبان السمك ويقرن كل طبق
مع نبيذ الأرز فقط أحاول إنشاء
مطعم أقوم به بنفسي  أود أن
أذهب على سبيل المثال إلى العداد الذي لدينا ،
لا أعتقد أن مطعم unagi العادي
سيحتوي على هذا النوع من العداد ، كما
أنني لا أعتقد أن هناك أي
مطاعم أخرى تجمع بين ثعبان البحر مع
ساكي الشرب اليابانية لماذا تشاهد
الطعام يجري  أعدت هو المفضل لدي
، ولهذا السبب صنعته حتى يتمكن العملاء من
مشاهدة الطعام الذي يتم تحضيره ، كل
ضيف يحصل على ثعبان البحر كامل
يتم توصيله طازجًا إلى المطعم كل
صباح.
بعد فترة وجيزة من وضعهم في أسياخ ،
سيُطردون للمرة الثانية
قبل أن يتم تقديمهم بين
الفينة والأخرى ، يقول موراتا إنه يبخر ثعبان البحر
لتليين اللحم وإزالة أي نكهات غير مرغوب فيها
يتطلب طهي ثعبان السمك الكثير من التقنية التي
قمنا بطهيها كل يوم ولكن  ما
زلنا نحاول ونفكر في الطرق التي يمكننا من خلالها
تحسين مذاقها
حتى اليوم ، ونحن
نجربها ، لقد أمضى مراد 13 عامًا في
مطعم أوناغي التقليدي قبل أن
يفتح مكانه الخاص ، كما يقول ،
ساعده ذو الخبرة في تحسين
نكهاته كما أحب  حقق توازنًا
بين الحلو والحار ، إنها صلصة توصلت إليها
أخيرًا بعد الكثير من
التجارب وتذوق
الصلصات المختلفة كل يوم حتى مرضت ومن
ثم بالطبع تحدث مراد
أكثر من 200 زجاجة
ويغير الأزواج كل شهر
موراتا  يقول أنه يرتفع أصعب شيء
لإقرانه مع نبيذ الأرز إنه يطبخ
أرزّه في قدر من الخزف ويقدمها مع
مخلوط من أجل أن
يكون طبقي المفضل هو una dong  نحن نقدمها على أنها الدورة الأخيرة ،
إنها تقليدية جدًا ومن
الرائع حقًا
أن يستمتع بها الناس بهذه الطريقة
أنت
[موسيقى]